two months ahead of time this is an
early review so I had the special
opportunity of seeing warhorse today one
of my most anticipated movies of the
rest of the year doesn't come out until
Christmas for goodness sakes Steven
Spielberg is my favorite director and
he's directed many films over the course
of 40 year 40 years since dual 1971 Wow
I believe I was actually a privileged
first audience to ever view this film
screen publicly I'm not positive on that
but I'm pretty sure
so warhorse tells the tale of a horse
that is raised by a boy at first he's
raised to be this farmhand but then one
England starts to fight Germany he is
bought by the army and then used in the
war and we use a really beautiful tale
that describes how this animal touches
the lives of people on all different
types of sides of this war well is it
it's a horse if I'm wandering about in
no-man's-land
kind of a Norse miraculous kind of it
almost be my guess
that's all I'm going to get into of the
plot because I'm going to spoil anything
because this is a magnificent film it's
completely different than how I thought
the film would be trailer gives away
nothing and that's fantastic because you
don't get that anymore trailers are so
stock filled with spoilers you know you
watch this trailer you get a feel for
the tone of the film and that's really
it one of the beautiful things about
this movie and I think probably the
movies greatest strength is the fact
that the movie is able to tell this tale
the way a horse
or an animal or someone some you know
creature not in the middle of a war not
understanding a war would view it a
horse would not look and say oh the
English yeah they're the people who
should win or the Germans yeah they're
the good guys the film never takes sides
and I think that is so fantastic because
that's exactly what an animal would
think
[Music]
the horse touches the lives of young
children Germans English everyone and
and I think that is just such a great
thing because this movie perfectly
captured the fact that an animal would
not take sides or or view one side is
better and that's so great in fact where
the film's best scenes involves two
different people on opposite sides of
the war working together to fix the
problems well the best scenes the movie
look for that when you see it John
Williams score is of course magnificent
I mean what what did you expect he's
never once disappointed me ever there's
like one person in Hollywood who has
never been disappointing it's John
Williams
[Music]
whoa that looks fantastic the scenic
shots in this film some of the scenes
you know all done in one shot like
classic Spielberg the film is actually
hilarious all of Spielberg's movies that
need it have a great underlying sense of
humor also the film has some of the best
war sequences I have ever seen one in
particular they had my mouth drop for
about a minute
it was pure Spielberg magic that scene
oh wow
I promise you Malala Karan if I can I'll
return him to you okay it's my ulcer
[Music]
the horse goes through different stories
and meets different people there was
just one story and then involved two
young boys that I wasn't interested in
at all it was probably the shortest
story so I have a feeling maybe
Spielberg knew that that was probably
the least investing one just that
segment of the film was about ten
minutes or so I was not really involved
with the film goes through so many
different shifts in regards to who this
horse meets and different stories that
at times it may have felt like it's just
went off track a tad I really think
Spielberg did a good job of keeping the
story on a good track but like I said
with that one little segment with the
two young boys I feel like it veered off
a little bit but quickly got back on it
looks magnificent it sounds great the
acting is very good it has a great sense
of humor it is very touching it is a
very touching movie and I just wanted to
hug a horse afterwards I just wanted to
walk up towards ability I love you horse
it's not et with a horse as some people
may have thought Kenny I mentioned
flying over a war
and you know you can never look down
there to look forward for you'll never
get home
[Music]
it's a very well-made film with
excellent war sequences and it really
excellently portrays how an animal would
view a situation like this unbiased and
I really really dug that the best films
I have seen of the year but because of a
few minor flaws I'm going to give the
film in a - if you like this review you
can subscribe to my channel and get
steppen eyes
[Music]